YURI GRINSHTEYN: Audit
logs in Google Cloud
provide an immutable
record of how
resources and data are created,
modified, and accessed.
But knowing what's
liked by default
and what you have control
over can be confusing.
Let's walk through setting
up and reading audit
logs to understand what's
really going on in your project.
This is the "Stack Doctor,"
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Actions that touch Google
Cloud resources or data
within those resources
create an audit trail.
But where do you go
to see that trail?
You can start on the
Activity tab of the homepage
of your project.
This is a view of all of the
audited events in your project,
and you get more
information about what
happened for each event.
Let's look at a
specific example.
We'll use Cloud storage and look
at both out-of-the-box audit
logs and those you
can enable yourself.
Start by creating a Cloud
Storage Bucket with a name
and default options.
Feel free to delete
this after you're done.
Now switch back to the
Activity tab and refresh.
Once the bucket
has been created,
you'll see a new event showing
the resource that was created,
the user who created it, and
the timestamp of the event.
You can also go to
Logging in the GCP console
and see the matching log entry.
It's an activity log
and the type audit log.
That's pretty straightforward.
You created a resource and
a log entry is written.
However, if you try adding
a file to your new bucket,
you'll see that no additional
activity or log entries
are generated as
a result. This is
because operating on
objects in buckets
is interacting
with user data, not
creating or modifying
the resources themselves.
To lock these actions, we'll
need to enable additional audit
logging.
You can find the Audit
Logging Configuration
under the IM an Admin
section of the Products menu.
This screen shows you
the kinds of audit
logs you can enable
for GCP services.
You should know that System
Event and Admin Activity audit
logs are always enabled
and cannot be turned off.
There are three kinds of
data access audit logs
you can enable.
Admin Read Logs are written
when you access Resource
Configuration or Metadata.
Data Read Logs are written when
user data within a resource
is accessed.
And Data Write Logs are written
when data within a resource
is created.
Let's continue with
our example to clarify.
If you enable Admin
to Read Audit Logs
and refresh the bucket
view in the console,
you'll see that a
new event is written.
This is a record of you
accessing the resource
as a metadata and configuration.
The actual log entry will show
a call to the storage buckets
GET API.
If you enable Data Read Audit
Logs and refresh the bucket,
you'll see an event written
for accessing resource data,
logging your call to the
storage object's List API.
If you then retrieve a file
from your storage bucket,
you'll see another event
created, showing you accessing
the resources data.
The log entry shows a call to
the storage object's GET API.
Finally, if you enable
Data Write Audit Logs
and create a new
file in the bucket,
you'll see an event for
inserting data, logging
a call to the storage
object's Create API.
That was a lot.
Let's review the kinds of
audit logs you can enable
and what actions they
can actually record.
You can turn on three
kinds of audit logs,
Admin Read for reading
metadata and configurations,
Data Read for reading
user data, and Data Write
for creating or writing
user data within resources.
Because these are
user-controlled,
they do incur logging
charges in the same way
as other logs in your project.
System Event and Admin Activity
logs are always written,
cannot be disabled,
and therefore,
don't incur logging charges.
Audit logging is
invaluable as you
work to keep your deployments
in GCP secure and compliant.
Knowing how to use Audit Logging
to get a clear record of what
happened in the project
is essential to keeping
a Google Cloud project secure.
And I hope that this helps
you to better understand
how to do that.
Thank you for joining me today,
and come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor,
stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]